parmi les candidates et candidats à
l'investiture figure elizabeth warren
qui propose de casser le monopole des
géants du web comme google facebook et
amazon
une telle chose est elle possible avec
nous catalina briceno professeur invité
à l'école des médias de l'uqam bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur finir que propose
d'abord elisabeth world en fait madame
warren parle de ça depuis un bon bout de
temps mais effectivement sa proposition
pour défaire la position de domination
des gaffes qu'on appelle repose
essentiellement sur deux mesures la
première c'est que d'abord reconnaître
que certaines plateformes rôle d'utilité
essentiel dans les transactions et les
interactions numériques des citoyens et
des citoyennes et par là donc considérer
que les plateformes technologiques qui
génère 25 milliards de dollars et plus
ne plus être à la fois donc propriétaire
de ces plateformes est là elle fait
l'analogie carrément avec un arbitre au
baseball c'est à dire la possibilité
d'établir des règles du jeu et être à la
fois fournisseur de produits ou de
services / ces mêmes plateformes
or c'est souvent le cas actuellement
avec les gaffes a donc qui vont être à
la fois je peux évidemment l'exemple le
plus le plus fraga flagrant c'est amazon
qui est à la fois propriétaire d'une
marque place de la place de marché du
magasin et en même temps que sa propre
ligne de produits donc qui peut avancer
avec derrière la capacité de collecter
toutes sortes d'informations de qui ont
un avantage concurrentiel énorme pour
pouvoir pousser en fait ou recommandés
ou valoriser ses propres produits au
détriment de celui de la concurrence
donc ce qu'elle dit ce qu'il faudrait
défaire en morceaux ces entreprises là
lors d'un côté le pôle droit d'être à la
fois plateforme et fournisseurs ou
d'avoir des activités de fournisseurs
sur ces plateformes et de l'autre
effectivement la possibilité de
carrément démanteler certaines fusions
qui aurait pu avoir lieu même au cours
même de manière rétroactive donc qui
aurait pu avoir lieu au cours des
dernières années comme lorsque
effectivement amazon par exemple le
racheter au foot en 2018 ou le fait par
exemple que facebook ait acheté
instagram et wat
sap qui leur donne une portée où est ce
qu'ils atteignent des milliards
d'utilisateurs sur la planète et elle
considère qu'elles sont donc ces
entreprises en position du pearl
dominance et qu'elles peuvent parle donc
prendre des avantages concurrentiels qui
pourrait nuire éventuellement donc aux
utilisateurs est ce que c'est réaliste
de penser de proposer sa et de penser le
faire bah écoutez ce serait peut-être
souhaitable mais déjà une partie de la
réponse à cette question se trouve dans
pourquoi les états unis par exemple qui
ont des lois antitrust compétition qui
ont un bureau de la concurrence
nos jeunes ne sont jamais intervenus à
ce jour pourquoi notamment l'union
européenne par exemple qui depuis
longtemps se préoccupe des pratiques
anticoncurrentielles des gaffes n'a pas
réussi à faire plier les google et léa
pool notamment de à ce jour une partie
de la réponse se trouve dans le fait
qu'au coeur puis le vous m'excuserez la
source simplification pour fins
d'explications mais au coeur des lois
anti concurrentielles donc antitrust il
y à la notion du bien être du
consommateur et parle on entend que la
concentration donc dans une industrie en
train de souvent le fait qu' on et off
la concurrence le moins de concurrents y
au moins d'offres et les prix augmentent
et que ultime ans était allons donc de
l'augmentation des prix est au coeur de
la nécessité de surveiller les marchés
ok parce que c'est des moins pratiques
abusives et c'est ici que c'est très
étrange parce que le modèle d'affaires
de ces grandes plateformes
technologiques déstabilise tout le monde
depuis des années puisqu'elle offre dans
beaucoup de cas leurs services et leurs
produits gratuitement et donc ce fameux
argument ou mesure le bien être du
consommateur est complètement démolie et
d'ailleurs google est devenu maître dans
l'art d'avancé ça pour faire fi donc des
poursuites et tout ça parce que il dit
au contraire
et comme de fait on utilise pompe et pas
pour le moteur de recherche on paye pas
pour utiliser notre jumelle on paye pas
pour aller sur facebook et c'est très
étrange et c'est ce qui est nouveau et
sans précédent dans l'histoire de
l'économie des entreprises devenu
multimilliardaire en ne vendant rien aux
consommateurs est-ce que ça nuit au
développement
un d'innovation de technologie de
nouvelles pousses que d'avoir des
entreprises très concentré très fortes
comme on a présentement oui alors c'est
définitivement une crainte parce
qu'évidemment partir du moment où
l'entrée sur le marché d'un nouveau
joueur devient très difficile lorsqu'on
est dans un marché extrêmement
concentrée l'industrie très concentré il
ya des possibilités d'étouffer
l'innovation je vous dirai aussi que ces
nuits non seulement aux jeunes pousses
ça nuit à toutes les petites entreprises
en général mais ce qui se produit et si
ce que ce qu'avance évidemment les
analystes actuellement aux etats-unis et
notamment madame morel mais également
certains républicains comme le sénateur
josh charles et je considère que c'est
également des pratiques anti capitaliste
donc ce qui se passe c'est que
lorsqu'une jeune pousse nouvelle
entreprise arrive par exemple avec un
nouveau produit service ou une
innovation qui pourrait être
intéressante pour le marché pour les
consommateurs et donc qui se trouve à
être une menace pour ses grandes
entreprises les joueurs dominants ont
tendance à devenir extrêmement hostile
en rachetant donc cette start up et ce
qui arrive dans le meilleur des cas
c'est qu'elles parviennent à développer
leurs produits au service au sein du
nouveau propriétaire de la corporation
mais évidemment selon laure les termes
et conditions du nouveau propriétaire
dans le pire des cas elles sont table
était en fait elles disparaissent et
lorsque même elle tente de demeurer
indépendantes comme ça a été le cas de
snapshot par exemple que refuser si je
ne m'abuse en 2013 d'être racheté par
facebook ce qui arrive c'est que
facebook derrière a racheté instagram et
a littéralement copier toutes les
innovations en fait et les
fonctionnalités les fonctionnalités de
snapshot très intéressant débat très
important catalina briceno merci
beaucoup
un plaisir